meantime we all know that having friends
is good for us but did you know that
they could provide more effective pain
relief than morphine according to a
study from Oxford University people who
have a large circle of friends have a
higher tolerance for pain joining us now
is Katerina Johnson who is a doctoral
student from the University of Optus
thanks for joining us on Sky News this
afternoon how so
what's the fact what is the science
behind this yes so we were really
interested in whether you know why
humans have different social network
sizes and in particular whether this may
relate to the activity of a chemical in
the brain called endorphin so endorphins
are part of both our pain and our
pleasure system they're our body's
natural painkillers and in fact dose per
dose there are more potent than morphine
but they're also responsible for giving
us those positive feelings we get you
know when we interact socially yeah but
endorphins don't you release those when
you go to the gym or you exercise so you
know you could actually be a lonesome
exerciser and get the the same benefit
is that the case yes so I mean many
people may have heard of endorphins in
relation to you know when you exercise
it can help give you that you know high
feeling afterwards so this may also be
the case in our study because an
interesting thing that we found was
actually individuals that were fitter
tended to have smaller social networks
and so we hypothesized that perhaps this
may be because both socializing and you
know when we exercise they both trigger
at the endorphin system so maybe people
use either socializing or sort of
exercising sort of as alternative means
to get this feel-good factor but of
course it made us be because you know if
you spend all your time in the gym
you're going to have you know less time
to spend with your friends what about
Katherine if you don't exercise much and
you don't have many friends you're in a
lot of trouble aren't here
well yes I guess so
well there's a bit of a tricky question
but you know we know that exercise input
is important for us you know for our
physical health and it can help relieve
stress but this study which sort of
emphasizes you know perhaps we should
consider social health you know as well
as our physical and our mental health
and this you know may even really be
important for you know health and
well-being generally and in fact studies
suggest that people who are better
integrated into society may even you
know live longer do you exercise a lot
and do you have lots of friends well I
do I am a keen athlete when when I'm not
I'm studying which takes up the most of
my time yeah I mean I'm not one of those
people on Facebook who has you know a
thousand friends but yeah I would I'd
like to say I have a good group of
friends and family that you know there
to support you and I mean that's what
you know really matters at the end of
the day but know our study does perhaps
suggest that you know maybe if we sort
of try to enhance the social health and
you know our feelings of connectedness
to others know perhaps this might you
know Primus better to you know deal with
physical pain but of course a lot more
sort of research is needed but it's
interesting because also for example a
study looking at chronic pain patients
does show that know if they increase
their social support and social
interaction this can actually help
reduce the pain that they feel just let
me check and just Jin release any
endorphins
does Jin yeah yes so alcohol is one of
the substances cat that can release
endorphins in the brain so this is
probably why you know people feel a bit
more sort of relaxed and comfortable
with socializing and in we had to bear
this in mind when we invited
participants in because that was one of
our exclusion criteria that it couldn't
have basically drunk lots of alcohol the
night before not that you know students
do that but yes so but you know we're
not saying to drink alcohol but um you
know obviously you know socializing with
your friends is a there's another sort
of way of you know you can get this you
know feeling of high and really it's
also important and relevant to you know
perhaps psychological disorders like
depression brilliant and perhaps being
on the telly as well gives you a little
bit of a high it's good to talk to you
thanks very much indeed for joining us
on Sky News this afternoon thank you
yeah thank you thanks